[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com senators are supposed to be
jurors in the impeachment of a president
and we learned that yesterday 21
Republican senators 21 over the 53
that's nearly 40% of the Republican
senators left the Senate chamber for
long periods of time while Adam Schiff
was arguing the case of the prosecution
during yesterday's day of Donald Trump's
Senate impeachment trial senators are
supposed to be in their seats during the
trial they are supposed to not miss the
proceedings
since this these proceedings are what
they will ultimately be using to decide
are we going to convict or are we going
to acquit the President of the United
States and yet 21 Republican senators
and two Democratic senators were missing
while Adam Schiff was laying out the
case they're not even pretending to take
this seriously and of course we know
they're not taking it seriously we know
they've already decided that they will
be voting to acquit the President of the
United States but they could at least
pretend to take it seriously
Michael McAuliffe was a congressional
reporter tweeted about this in the
middle of the day yesterday saying quote
just counted 21 empty seats on the
Republican side of the Senate - on the
Democratic side a couple of hours into
Adams shifts presentation some are just
stretching their legs but most are not
in the chamber some of them have been
out of there for a while they're
supposed to decide the fate of Donald
Trump based on the evidence and they are
missing the evidence and we talked on
yesterday's live stream of the
proceedings about how Chief Justice John
Roberts who's presiding over impeachment
as the Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court does John Roberts role is
procedural it is not to evaluate the
evidence or render an opinion
part of the procedure that John Roberts
is supposed to be enforcing are the
basic rules like senators must be there
during the proceedings and this actually
may be part of why we only get two
camera angles the entire time c-span has
said they've requested to be allowed to
use their cameras in the Senate and to
control their cameras Mitch McConnell
does not want that and when you look at
the the production of the stream unless
something's changed in the last few
hours there's a shot of the outside of
the Senate which I believe is still a
c-span camera and then there are two
shots we get two camera angles there's
like a zoomed in shot of the area where
Schiff and Nadler and the different
house managers impeachment managers
stand and then there's a slightly wider
shot that lets you see the front of the
room the tables were Donald Trump's
defense attorneys and the house
impeachment managers and John Roberts
are pictured but no real shots of the
chamber since we would all immediately
realize where the hell are the Senators
this is sick and disgusting and and it
is a sham Republicans have been saying
this is a sham they're right it's a sham
but it's a sham because 40% of them are
gone for long portions of Adams shifts
and other presentations in a sense it's
almost as if there are 53 empty seats
right because they're all as far as we
know going to vote to acquit Donald
Trump regardless of the evidence and
like I said yesterday on Twitter how
will they decide whether to convict or
acquit Trump if they don't see the
testimony oh that's right they don't
need to it's an absolute and total farce
we're doomed in a sense here and this is
not even really a matter of partisanship
per se it's just childish behavior it's
image who are elected officials it's a
with a lot of them you know we keep
hearing it ever this is boring and it's
it's boring but you are deciding about
whether a president who is only the
third president ever to be impeached is
going to become the first president ever
to actually be convicted on impeachment
and they're bored they're bored and
they're walking around while Adam Schiff
is presenting evidence it's a truly
sorry bunch and because of the coverage
on Fox News and elsewhere where
which I'm going to talk about
momentarily a huge portion of the
country will not even hear that 40% of
Republicans were gone during much of
Adam Schiff speech it won't even enter
their echo chamber at all ever but it
reinforces once again for better or
worse our voice mail today argues that
this is for worse every day of this
reinforces that there's one way to hold
Donald Trump accountable I don't even
have to say it we all know what it is
and it would be done in November let me
just put it that way it's nine and a
half months away he won't be convicted
on impeachment he's not going to be
indicted criminally after he's out of
office yesterday I got questions during
our live stream about how likely do you
think it is Trump gets indicted when he
finally leaves office I don't think it's
likely at all I would not take that bet
we have one shot to force him to suffer
a consequence and it's by voting him out
in November let's now talk about Fox
News's coverage Fox News is doing
something that is evil genius I have to
hand it to them like that it's actually
genius what they are doing if Fox News
were to say we're not going to talk
about the impeachment trial we're not
going to show that there is an
impeachment trial going on they would
rightly be called out because that would
be completely absurd we've had three
presidents impeached in the history of
the United States Andrew Johnson was in
the 19th century before we had 24-hour
news and the internet and satellite
television and all of this stuff the
other was Bill Clinton in the 1990s and
now we have Donald Trump not covering
impeachment would be crazy even for Fox
News they would be called out it would
not be something that they would be able
to to to bear so Fox News has figured
out a way to have impeachment on the TV
screen but not to really cover it and to
propagandize directly through the
impeachment proceedings yesterday the
impeachment managers the prosecutors as
they effectively are in the impeachment
of Donald Trump they had their first
three days of presenting their case it
was long it was nearly eight of their 24
hours that they have allocated for this
it was very nuanced and detailed and
there were exhibits videos tweets text
messages but Adam Schiff and
the others did a very good job of laying
out the big picture of Donald Trump's
wrongdoing starting to sort of lay out
the arc of it Fox News often showed it
on mute meaning without audio including
going to commercials while impeachment
was going on and they can say we covered
it if you turned on fox news there were
hours and hours where you could see that
impeachment proceedings were going on
you couldn't hear it it was on the
screen though you couldn't hear what was
being said they ran commercials later
they ran right-wing commentary lying
about the content of the proceedings
while you could see but not hear the
proceedings so let's look at a few clips
I have a bunch of these here's a
commercial for some kind of bed linen or
pillow or something when Adam Schiff is
speaking about how the president
committed high crimes and misdemeanors
and should be removed from office each
and every one of you get the best sleep
of your life that's why I created my new
Giza dreams bed she's I guarantee you
they'll be the most comfortable sheets
you'll ever own but now every Network
has commercials that by itself is not a
huge thing but this was all day here's
another example of when congresswoman
Val Demmings was laying out her part of
the narrative and as Aaron reparse said
on Twitter Fox has the optics of
covering the impeachment trial without
really covering it they show the
proceedings with no audio while the
hosts provide Trumpy and spin here's
Jesse Watters saying they should call
hunter Biden to the trial you get to
call whoever you want and one of the
reasons you call hunter is ask him what
the hell he was doing over there and why
he was doing it because that's why he
was making that phone call partially The
Wall Street Journal wrote I mentioned
this in an editorial that if you're
arguing there was a corrupt motive that
that Trump have then and if he was
investigating Hunter Byron's activities
well let's explore that and let's
explore what hunter Biden told his
father the vice-president about his
business in Ukraine let's ask Obama
energy saw Amos Hochstein who raised
concerns about Joe Biden and his aides
about hunter Biden's Ukrainian ties and
then there was Chris Hines former
Secretary of State John Kerry's stepson
broke business with hunter Biden because
of his work with Purisima he called it
unacceptable so let's let's cover all
that
just really quickly hey they covered it
right I mean you couldn't hear a damn
word that was said you could only hear
pro-trump spin and conspiracy theories
but it was on the screen you could see
Val Demmings moving her mouth there then
at night mind you this was still while
the proceedings were going on because
they went from about 1:00 to nearly 9:45
p.m. Eastern Time Sean Hannity instead
of showing you what Adam Schiff is
saying sums up the proceedings as we
learned nothing at all and there's
nothing notable here and Adam Schiff
looked like a crazy person manufacturing
consent telling you what to think after
a full day of telling you what to think
here's what you missed from today's
schumer chef sham show charade made it
again we learned absolutely nothing new
today not one new piece of information
instead we got hours and hours and hours
literally of the compromised corrupt
congenital liar
Adam Schiff Wow never-ending non-stop
feigned moral outrage and then here's
Tucker Carlson also again the
proceedings were still going on
just ridiculing the entire thing right
there the Senate impeachment trial is
still going it's been in progress all
day they would be forgiven if you didn't
watch every single minute of it imagine
a movie written and directed by children
whose ending you already know and by the
way it's 20 hours long
in Hungarian with misspelled subtitles
that's what it's like we've been
monitoring it anyway all day because
that's what we do and we'll alert you if
anything interesting happens during this
hour so understand you could watch Fox
News all day and in some technical sense
you'd be watching the impeachment trial
except you would have heard commercials
for my pillow
instead of Adam Schiff you would have
heard Jesse Watters and Egan McDowell
talk about we got to get hunter Biden to
testify as if that's what this is really
about and then you would be able to
finish out the day with Tucker Carlson
and Sean Hannity spoon-feeding you that
you didn't miss anything
all the impeachment managers are making
fools out of themselves and there's
nothing to see here whatsoever
these are
on propaganda tactics okay this is how
you end up with people who say Trump did
nothing wrong
did you watch the trial though you would
say to them and they'd say you know I
did I watched the trial but did you hear
anything that they said or did you see
atom shifts mouth moving while Tucker
Carlson and Sean Hannity told you there
was actually nothing to see here
well no I guess I watched it but I
didn't really hear anything but Trump
definitely did nothing wrong it's a very
sad state of affairs and it's part of
reinforcing when Republicans ultimately
vote to acquit everybody will feel
trumpets I mean that they did the right
thing a Fox News viewer on the day that
the acquittal of Donald Trump happens
they will hear Trump was acquitted and
they will think back to you know I
remember watching on Fox News and I
didn't hear anything damning about
Donald Trump during the trial
well Fox ran it on mute while their
commentators told you that there was
nothing to see here
and then they'll think you had the
Republicans voted the right way because
I don't remember hearing anything very
damning about what Donald Trump did
manufacturing consent it's out of a
textbook and the story of how right-wing
media is handling this is a huge part of
the story and when the history of this
is written I hope that's included with
with Andrew Johnson's impeachment of
course the technology wasn't there to
manufacture consent in this way with
Bill Clinton's impeachment well that was
the impeachment of a Democrat so the
rules are completely completely
different when it comes to how
right-wing media will cover it and of
course we didn't have social media then
like we do now this is a huge event for
the United States of America in and of
itself but the manufacturing of consent
the media narratives the spin are a huge
part of it and we can't forget that let
me know what you think about how Fox
News has been covering this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman follow me on Twitter
at D Pakman and let me know what you
make of how the write has been covering
the impeachment
Donald from the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are james Beaudry and lucas schedule
Asst i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly james and lucas thanks for
your support i also want to say thanks
to melissa powers Melissa's today's
longtime sustaining member of the day we
do have we are celebrating the
impeachment trial of Donald Trump with a
coupon code impeach fifty one hundred
and three people so far have taken
advantage of that coupon code which will
save you 50% impeach 50 take advantage
yourself at WWJ pakman.com a lot of
discussion on the david pakman show
subreddit about the Democratic primary
including Hillary Clinton's recent
comments about Bernie Sanders remember
find the subreddit
at david pakman.com slash our EDD i.t
nearly 17,000 of our viewers and
listeners currently subscribed to the
subreddit a few interesting posts blue
rice posted will Hillary's attack on
Bernie backfire referring to Hillary
Clinton saying recently that Bernie
Sanders that nobody likes Bernie Sanders
the post says I am rooting for Bernie or
Warren to win the nomination much like
David Australia desperately needs
progressive leaders in light of the bush
fires and I think a progressive
president would help shift the world's
population to that kind of thinking
having said that I'm not optimistic
about bernier Warren's chances but I
want to see what effect Hillary's attack
on Bernie will have if any my question
is does Hillary exemplify the mainstream
politics that the US seemed to reject in
2016 when not considering the popular
vote more than Biden does if it
continues to be publicized could
Hillary's attack paint Bernie has more
of an anti-establishment choice and
invigorate a different section of
Democratic voters or as Bernie already
seen as an anti-establishment candidate
amongst us voters I believe Bernie is
already very clearly seen as an
anti-establishment candidate sometimes
to a fault in the sense that he is
couched
this outrageous radical who wants to
tear down all of the basic
infrastructure systems we have which
isn't true is just a social democrat in
the sort of northern european sense but
I do believe that Hillary Clinton's
attack could backfire the thing is the
backfire there's there's two degrees the
first is could it backfire and get
Bernie the nomination question two is
what would happen if Bernie is the
nominee - the chances of removing Donald
Trump and fortunately for all of us we
have new polling about that which we
will be talking about a little bit later
today another post on the subreddit from
a user who goes by the name pedantically
Symantec says is david wrong about
calling Bernie's label of democratic
socialism inaccurate adding that there
does seem to be an overlap in semantics
meaning if the definition of social
socialism is the public ownership of the
means of production and the public is
not specifically stated as only the
government and the public can also mean
a collective of the public like
cooperatives of cooperatives and
capitalism is defined as the private
ownership and private can mean an
individual can own so as you can see
this is a very semantically intense
question I want to just answer it from
the top level which is as we've
addressed before if democratic socialism
now is being understood to mean social
democracy isn't it true that bernie is a
democratic socialist if what we mean by
democratic socialist is is just social
democrat I don't even think we need to
have that conversation the conversation
that I've had is that when socialism is
discussed in many circles the actual
definition is still used and so for
clarity I believe it makes more sense
for Bernie to say that he is running a
candidacy on social democracy not
democratic socialism I concede that over
time in society if we start using a
different word for something or if we
change the definition of a word these
are things we can determine and that may
be the case I don't believe we've gotten
to that point and I think that there is
only more confusion not less when
Bernie Sanders is called a Democratic
Socialist even though the policies are
the policies of social democracy people
can disagree about this that's my view
as of right now join the discussion at
david pakman.com slash read it things
can change very quickly as we close in
on the first votes being cast in the
2020 Democratic primary just look at the
last 24 hours which have been very good
very good for senator Bernie Sanders
yesterday I told you 24 hours ago I told
you that Joe Biden had picked up some
support both nationally and in Iowa in
recent polls the good news came in a big
wave over the last 24 hours for Bernie
Sanders and let's go through it we have
a new national poll a new California
poll and a new hypothetical matchups
poll against Donald Trump to look at
let's go through them one at a time
starting with a national poll the big
story a new CNN poll has Bernie leading
nationally the poll says Bernie 27 Joe
Biden 24 there's a three and a half
point margin of error so technically it
could be tied but again a shift in
momentum in the direction of Bernie
Sanders in this same poll Elizabeth
Warren is polling just 14 if we are to
believe recent polls we really have a
two candidate race right now this is
really Biden and Bernie one of them will
be the nominee if we can believe recent
polls if recent polls can be trusted
Elizabeth Warren is all but out of this
thing
not polling in second place anywhere
unless you go all the way back to an IBD
poll that is like 15 or 20 polls old at
this point in time we'll get to more of
that in a second next new polling out of
California we're in a University of
Southern California Rossier School of
Education poll that's a mouthful bernie
is leading bernie 28 biden 24 now what's
important to understand about california
california is a huge state population
wise many delegates to be had from
california but very unlikely that
california will be a difference maker in
the primary i'll explain why california
apportions delegates in proportion to
the percentage of the vote that
different candidates get so if Bernie
beats Biden 28 to 24 they get a very
similar number of Delegates out of
California 28 and 24 percent
respectively if the numbers are flipped
it's still a very similar number of
Delegates for the two of them so
California is important momentum wise
it's a huge state and for PR purposes
it's important but understand that you
know in 2016 Bernie lost the California
primary to Hillary Clinton but he had
like 46 percent of the vote and got
roughly 46 percent of the delegates this
time because it's a bigger field Bernie
may win but actually end up with fewer
delegates than he did in 2016 but that's
for the future once the first four
primaries are out of the way we'll look
at California in more detail and then
third and maybe most interestingly we
have another one of these hypothetical
matchup polls where people are said if
the nominee were Bernie how would you
vote on Trump vs. Bernie if the nominee
were Biden how would you work on trunk
how would you vote on Trump versus Biden
and the results are compelling this is
from survey USA consisting of more than
4,000 registered voters the numbers are
fascinating the person with the biggest
lead over Trump is Bernard Sanders 52 to
43 Trump - 9 against Bernie Biden is
defeating Trump by 7 in the hypothetical
matchup Bloomberg leading Trump by 6
Warren leading Trump by 3 Budaj edge
leading Trump by 3 but with more
undecideds Andrew yang leading Trump by
2 even Tom Steyer is even with Trump the
two candidates that lose to Trump in the
hypothetical matchups Amy Klobuchar and
Tulsi Gabbard losing by the most Trump
ahead of Tulsi by 5 which will anger a
small but loud portion of my audience so
what's the takeaway knowing that the
establishment is going to run a
full-court press for Joe Biden
throughout the primary what this tells
us is we've got a real race here and the
races Biden versus
when it comes to facing Trump Bernie is
regularly doing the best against Trump
compared to other candidates that
shouldn't be ignored when we think about
electability unless someone can explain
to me how Warren is still in this thing
I don't see her having a path to the
nomination so my question to you is can
we now say that this is almost
completely a two candidate race Biden
versus Bernie or do you still see Warren
or anybody else having a path to the
nomination I also can't restate the
importance enough that the we want to
have a primary that doesn't hurt our
chances of removing Donald Trump so
yesterday I talked about Hillary
Clinton's comment that nobody likes
Bernie and her hesitation to say she
would support Bernie if he is the
nominee
that's the self-destructive garbage that
is the last thing we need the absolutely
last thing we need right now let's get
out there let's support the people we
like based on their policies let's vote
let's then rally around the removal of
Donald Trump a very solid couple of days
for Bernie Sanders reminder my question
to you is Warren still in this thing she
seems to be out to me but I want to hear
from you we will continue our coverage
of this on our Instagram page make sure
you're following the David Pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show while
you're there follow me at David Koch the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
Sean McFate who is senior fellow at the
Atlantic Council and also author most
recently of the new rules of war victory
in the age of durable disaster Sean it's
so great to have you back great to be
back with you Dave so we've been
following a lot of different
geopolitical and also sort of military
related stories we had what looked like
it was heading in the direction of a big
escalation with Iran that did not happen
we've been talking about the possible
different paths that the future of the
three big superpowers the US China and
Russia could could potentially take and
in that context talking about technology
militaries China's declining birthrate
and all of these different factors that
that could play a role if you just word
a big picture for us the changes that
we've seen - the dynamics of the
superpowers over the last couple of
years under Donald Trump how what has
changed I guess is maybe where to start
well the first thing is that Donald
Trump is really doubling down on the
defense budget or the US military budget
is bigger than the next seven biggest
militaries in the world combined
it's sort of like the wrong Reagan
buildup and I think in some ways and
there's a shift away from terrorism to
great power competition like Russia and
China Iran and in some ways that smart
but what's not smart is what we're
investing in and how we think we're
gonna fight those Wars if it becomes a
war can you give some examples of that
in the sense that I mean I think we
we've talked about how whenever there is
a discussion of a possible war now our
minds probably still go to the type of
warfare of times past and that's not
realistically what it would look like
but but what would it look like what
would the sort of battle lines be so
in the in the old rules of war the way
you won war is battlefield victory take
a Waterloo Gettysburg Stalingrad Midway
but what was the last time battlefield
victory swayed a war in the last 70
years no meant no times so warfare has
changed we think in terms of
conventional war we think that the
future war is good like world war two
with better technology but in fact where
work where war is gone - is strategic
deception and what matters now is worse
begin epistemological so what matters
now is not like battlefield victory it
matters what people and populations
think so what does victory look like now
well let me ask you a question I mean
like right now we're we're engaged a
cultural war on the assets America right
Fox vs. CNN Democrats was Republican all
those things now we know that
democracies are messy and that's okay if
we're having an organic family dispute
what's not okay is if foreign powers are
funding the fissures in our society and
Flajnik Fanning those flames
deliberately and that's indeed what's
going on it's a form of warfare it's and
it's not something that f-35 can fight
is it so I understand what you're saying
I still though so let me give you a
counter example and see where you think
it fits in in the discussion of a
possible escalation with Iran we saw
some pretty good pieces that said from a
strategy and tactics perspective Iran
will be very different than Iraq Iran's
military is much stronger than Iraq the
land the sort of geographical realities
of Iran are very different than Iraq
mountainous and and very different those
seem like analyses more related to the
sort of traditional battlefield and they
seem relevant are they are they
partially relevant are they relevant in
a different way or is that not even a
reasonable analysis to be making it's
not a reasonable analysis at all really
I mean no I mean to invade Iran would be
like to invade China or to invade Moscow
you know both the Napoleon and the Nazis
learned not to invade Russia
yeah just because you have more troops
and more bullets does not mean you're
going to win wars so what's going on and
look around what's going on in Iran
right now well we know we killed I mean
we know that Iran and Russia the last 10
years have really come to dominate
Middle East politics we kind of lost and
Russia is filling the void and so as
Iran and the way they're fighting is not
like the iraq-iran war of days of old
they're using secret type of weapons
using spats they were using a cut
Special Forces Hezbollah terrorists
proxy groups propaganda all these things
and you know what so does Russia they
use Spetsnaz they use mercenaries like
the vogner group they use little green
men these fake proxy militias they use
propaganda and active measures that's
how they took the Crimea right and this
is also how Iran is taking the Levant
kind of taking Syria and they're doing
it not through troops on the ground and
tanks and mountainous they're doing it
through deception and the reason is is
that we live in an Information Age where
weapons that give you plausible
deniability like terrorists and special
forces of propaganda weapons that give
you plausible deniability or more potent
than firepower we in the u.s. are still
focusing on firepower but warfare has
completely changed Iran and Russia fight
this way we do not hmm so let's let's
keep talking about firepower a little
bit then nuclear weapons yeah a lot of
the conversation around Iran stemmed
from the 2015 Iran nuclear deal which as
far as we knew at the time that Donald
Trump decided to bail on it
Iran was abiding by of course since then
Iran has now said well if the u.s. is
out we're not going to abide by it
anymore
can you talk a little bit about in the
new sort of framework of what war would
look like what role do nuclear weapons
have because often the conversation is
merely about if the u.s. gets to have
them who are we to say Iran doesn't the
legitimacy of the UN Security Council
that's often the conversation I got a
call or a couple of
ago who said you know David what's not
being discussed is it's possible that
Iran getting nuclear weapons could be a
moderating influence in the sense that
sometimes once countries have nuclear
weapons they see themselves as part of a
sort of different tier or a chillon and
it can actually tone down radical
rhetoric what what do you think about
that where do you come down on the role
of nuclear weapons in new warfare it's a
great question first of all the jcpoa
jcpoa is on hospice care it's done and
we also know that Russia is working
behind the scenes the UN to let the arms
embargo on Iran expire so that come
October we can see you know Iran and
Russia really doubling down on
conventional weapons terms of nuclear
weapons WMD it's probably inevitable
that we that Iran at some point will get
a nuclear weapon we can bomb Natanz with
a nuclear we'll take a nuclear weapon
maybe a JDAM to hit it that will slow it
down we can also try to assassinate
their scientists as Israel is done that
can slow it down but I think we have to
be prepared to live in a world that may
have a nuclear Iran and if they do we
have to ask ourselves are they really
going to deploy it and everybody assumes
they're going to deploy it and I don't
know if that's true people send us about
in North Korea before North Korea became
nuclear and in fact once Iran is a
nuclear power we still have levers of
power levers of diplomacy we can pull on
them it's not Armageddon despite their
fierce rhetoric I'm not being an
apologist for Iran but there are people
who treat it like ass the moment they
get a nuclear weapon is a moment you
know you know Tel Aviv and New York City
go up in a mushroom cloud and I think
some of that is just fear-mongering well
there's no question that the use of a
nuclear weapon would be would be
self-destructive there's no question
about that but I guess the broader
question is when it comes to policy
would the presence of or the more
serious potential to have a nuclear
weapon
make that country perceived as more
important to negotiate with I mean there
are examples from history we can look at
Iran we can look at you know within
within the Soviet Union instances where
there has been disarming where there
have been agreements to disarm that the
future has not gone particularly well
for some of those countries so if you
look at history it's understandable why
countries would see nuclear weapons or
at least the serious potential of them
as a good negotiating tool or something
that's good to have that's right I mean
look at North Korea they were they were
treated as a b-list player at best
before they got nuclear weapons now
people pay attention to them when they
may they speak and they're not gonna
give up a nuclear weapon despite
whatever the Trump administration
promises look at Ukraine they gave up
their nuclear weapons after the Serbian
collapsed the United States promised
them oh we'll protect you of Russia ever
gets aggressive and then when Russia got
aggressive in 2014 the u.s. broke its
promise so I think the entire world
knows that's better to have nuclear
weapons than not it shouldn't just go to
the victors of you know world war two I
think the danger is a nuclear world war
one Syria of a moment if Iran ever gets
a nuclear weapon we know Israel has
nuclear weapons and many believe that
Saudi Arabia has a secret deal with
Pakistan Saudi Arabia used to have a
nuclear program 70s 80s and the u.s.
they you know talk them out of it but
some believe that they that Saudis made
a secret do a Pakistan giving them all
the research and all their money and
said you develop nuclear weapons and if
we ever need one we'll just secretly buy
a dozen from you and so very quickly we
could have a nuclear Iran you know Saudi
Arabia Israel and there's a threat of
accidental war like a 1914 Syria of a
moment but it doesn't last for four
years at last you know 30 minutes and
that would be tragic what do you see is
the role of organizations like the
United Nations we've talked about NATO a
lot since Donald Trump has been
president and
defense treaties there's this streak of
both I mean it starts with nationalism
but it often leads to a sort of
isolationism in some cases what what do
you see is the role of multinational
organizations joint defense treaties etc
in the next 10 to 15 years um it's a
great question I mean first of all the
question of NATO is long overdue and
Donald Trump's not the first person
asked what's their mission right that's
that's hardly new
I do you think that international
organizations United Nations have passed
their expiration date they have failed
to evolve with the world right now we're
in a world where you know it's not the
world that we imagine the world
diplomats imagine is state centric you
know states are everything and
everything that's not state is called
sub state politics but we live in a
world with a fortune 500 are more
powerful than most states where the
super bo-duper rich the 0.1% globally
are more powerful than than the most
states and we're mercenaries are back so
anybody who's rich enough can can go to
war for any reason they want that means
anybody can swipe a paycheck to become a
superpower eventually Exxon Mobil gets
its own army Bill Gates's gets his own
army megachurches oligarchs they all get
their own militaries so the UN is still
stuck in the state centric worldview and
they're not though they're not likely to
leave that and so is international law
which is why they become less and less
relevant from mitigating and managing
conflicts around the world whether
that's Rwanda or the Congo or Iraq or
Afghanistan at most or just a rubber
stamp they're just they're like they're
stationed area and most and I think they
either have a you don't have to evolve
or they're just going to become lip
service what would what would the
evolution of an organization like NATO
look like of NATO I think that NATO is I
think NATO's past as expiration date
because after after the Cold War it
stopped becoming a military alliance
became a pro-democracy alliance and now
it's it's kind of run half by diplomat
diplomatic think and half by military I
think
if there's going to be a real alliance
of collective security lines look at
what Poland is doing on the east so
Eastern Europe they take Russia's threat
very seriously and they're kind of
forming a an informal security
cooperation pact and I think something
like that might be more of a model but
it needs to be they would have to be
once and again seized with defense as
its primary mission and not being used
as a tool for you know human rights and
democracy as important as those things
are that's not the original nature of a
defense alliance we've been speaking
with Shaun McFate who is a senior fellow
at the Atlantic Council also author most
recently of the book the new rules of
war victory in the age of durable
disaster Shaun so great having you on
today
thank you David speaking back to
yourself the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
if you watched the Donald Trump's
impeachment trial date 3 yesterday on
Fox News you might not have heard much
about this because they ran a lot of the
proceedings on mute running my pillow
commercials over the impeachment
proceedings or you had hosts talking
over the proceedings talking about how
hunter Biden is really what this
impeachment trial should be about but
that did not stop Donald Trump from
absolutely losing his mind and tweeting
a record for him 141 times in one day
that was only up until 6 p.m. and then
it continued I've told you before when
Donald Trump seemingly spends the entire
day doing nothing but tweeting sometimes
dozens of tweets once I think he got
into the 80s or 90s we didn't see that
much Twitter activity from Donald Trump
on Tuesday but I'm now realizing that
was because he was still at the World
Economic Forum in Davos Switzerland and
then traveling back eventually yesterday
he had more time back in Washington DC
and I think sitting on Air Force One and
he broke his own personal record for
tweets and retweets in a single day
tweeting 141 times by 6:00 p.m. Eastern
continuing into the night and this
morning
most of the tweets are either tweets or
retweets of extremists Republican quotes
videos and statements sometimes just
absolute nonsense conspiracy theories
from Donald Trump the tweets include
Trump's and his friends attacks on the
house impeachment managers who sort of
are the prosecutors in the impeachment
trial including of course a favorite
target of Trump's is extreme anger at
Adam Schiff Trump this morning including
a mostly capitalized tirade of course a
hallmark of Trump is tweets both Trump
and his supporters are when you get set
up to tweet you turn caps lock on and
you turn spellcheck off that's how if
you're getting yourself set up to tweet
Trump is stuff you've got a disable
spellcheck and enable caps lock this
morning Donald Trump sang Attorney
General's oh I mean it's it's attorneys
general I know that Trump doesn't
Attorney General's from 21 states
are urging the Senate to reject capital
I impeachment they say the articles have
legal and factual problems and the
Democrats case sets a dangerous
historical precedent missing an
apostrophe random capitalization and
then now caps-lock engaged buckle in
folks all caps even an unsuccessful
effort to impeach the president
undermines the integrity of the 20/20
election because it weapon eise's a
process that should only be initiated in
exceedingly rare circumstances and
should never be used for partisan
purposes the Democrats are trying hard
to damage Republicans prior to the
capital e election I'm sweating now
here's what you need to understand 141
tweets by 6:00 p.m. if he started at
midnight that's 18 hours
okay 141 tweets in 18 hours is eight
tweets per hour
that's one tweet every seven and a half
minutes but that's if he's not sleeping
at all and just tweeting for 18 hours
straight if we assume that Trump tweeted
141 times starting at you know 5:00 a.m.
maybe which sounds insane to you or I
but but you know to you or me
between 5 a.m. and 6 p.m. 141 tweets
that's 11 tweets per hour meaning a
tweet every five and a half minutes it's
the President of the United States he's
sending out a tweeter retweet every five
minutes for an entire workday this
amount of tweeting isn't normal for
anyone if I look at my Twitter feed and
I see someone at messaged me five times
in an hour
I immediately mute them I don't have
time for this nonsense Trump is tweeting
141 times in a day and it's funny in a
way to see him so triggered on Twitter
it is funny to see Donald Trump at these
world events like Davos as the guy none
of the other world leaders really want
to talk to the idea of the adults are
meeting about important things and Trump
is on his phone tweeting that's a
hilarious image but it's really bad it's
an embarrassment it's a laughingstock
for the United States I don't even have
time to read a hundred and forty one
tweets in a day and Donald Trump is send
out a hundred and forty-one tweets and
retweets I expect that this is going to
get even worse once the Republicans take
over their defense of Donald Trump in
the Senate and the reason why is that a
lot of Donald Trump Donald Trump's
Twitter activity is retweeting videos
that are people saying nice things about
him or defending him once his lawyers
Pat Cipollone II and Jay Sekulow once
they take over I think Donald Trump
could potentially even break his own
record of 141 tweets and retweets in a
single day speaking of Donald Trump at
Davos Donald Trump has targeted a 17
year old kid in a completely incoherent
tirade at the Davos World Economic Forum
in Switzerland I happened to be talking
about 17 year-old Swedish climate
activists Greta toon Berg Donald Trump
included in his screed that she quote
barely beat him out to be on the cover
of Time magazine the President of the
United States a 73 year old billionaire
is attacking a 17 year-old autistic kid
who just wants to save the planet this
is where we are in 2020 it's sick it's
disgusting but we're sort of used to the
fact that this is where we are and the
reality is it's going to continue if and
until this guy is removed in November of
2020 ultimately leaving office in
January of 2021 Donald Trump also maybe
even more disturbingly said that Greta
toon burg should really focus on the
pollution of other countries because the
United States is doing fine which is a
crazy thing to say let's take a look at
the clip and then discuss that's good
but what is your response to who beat me
Evan Time magazine what did you hear
from were other world leaders and
business leaders who said that they
think that she has a message no I did
was actually but I would have loved to
have seen her speak I did not
no and not at all I think what is I
think aspects of it are I think that
some people are they put it at a level
that is you know unrealistic to a point
you can't live your lives we want to
have the cleanest water on earth we want
to have the cleanest air on earth our
numbers as you saw we had record numbers
come out very recently our numbers are
very very good our environmental numbers
our water numbers are numbers on air are
tremendous we have to do something about
other continents we have to do something
about other countries when we're clean
and beautiful and everything's good but
you have another continent where the
fumes are rising at levels that you
can't believe I mean I think Greta
auto-focus are those places but we are
doing better right now than we've ever
done in terms of cleanliness in terms of
numbers we have a beautiful ocean called
the Pacific Ocean with thousands and
thousands of tons of garbage flows
toward us and that's put there by other
countries so I think Greta has to start
working on those other countries so just
the fact that he's attacking a kid is
insane that he's obsessed with Greta
Thun Berg it's very very weird and in
fact I've previously spoken about how
it's bizarre how easily and totally
triggered the right is by Greta toon
Berg it's not just Trump it's a kid who
wants to save the planet and who speaks
in a way that inspires a lot of people
to take seriously this issue of the
climate and pollution and climate change
and so many Republicans are just so
instantly triggered by Greta tune Berg
but then Donald Trump said the u.s. is
clean and beautiful and Greta should be
focusing elsewhere that's wrong the
United States is a huge disproportionate
polluter and user of fossil fuels on a
per capita basis it's the opposite of
what Donald Trump says in reality there
are many countries that pollute the
United States on a per capita basis
disproportionately does so but it
shouldn't really come as a surprise that
Donald Trump is spreading misinformation
on this issue because he did say climate
change is a hoax created by the Chinese
to bolster their manufacturing
industry Trump lost out to a teenager
who wants to save the planet for being
on the cover of Time magazine and he's
furious and he's taking it out of her
nice little presidency we have here not
embarrassing at all and then I
remembered Melania Trump Donald Trump's
wife one of her issues was being against
bullying when she was asked what are
what are the key issues going to be
Michelle Obama nutrition and the White
House garden and vegetables and you know
it was one a very prominent issue for
Michelle Obama for Melania it was going
to be bullying she doesn't like bullying
her husband is bullying a child her
husband is bullying a child who's doing
something good I think it's important to
add but don't even dare mention Baron
Trump's name by the way that would be
completely and totally off-limits even
saying his name is not allowed the
reality around the world at a global
level is that this seventeen-year-old
kid
17 year old Greta soon Berg at the
global level is more respected than
Donald Trump and Trump on some level
probably perceives that people react
more positively to Greta toon burg than
to him when she walks in the room
compared to when he walks in the room
unless it's a hand-picked crowd at a
sick of Fanta crowley and he can't take
it and he's attacking a kid again it's
truly incredible we have a voicemail
number that number is two one nine to
david p this voicemail is very timely in
the context of impeachment in the
context of what we expect to be an
acquittal of donald trump along party
lines in the senate let's take a listen
hey David names landed Letterman from
East Tennessee hey Landon I just had a
question about impeachment and all this
is that I mean I I'm not trying to play
the importance of voting but if voting
is the only means of dealing with a
corrupt president yes in terms of the
way Donald Trump has lived his life at
all rights and why do we have a system
of justice it just seems pointless to me
that that's the only recourse get back
to me on this
ya know Linden you're completely right I
mean this is a this is what I've been
saying for a while the molar
investigation was never going to remove
Donald Trump go back and look at my
videos from I don't even know but April
of 2017 I said if you're waiting around
for this to remove Trump it's not going
to the 25th amendment possibility the
cabinet you know if you're waiting all
right that this is clearly a guy who's
impaired either from in a medical sensor
in a colloquial sense it's not going to
work
impeachment we know it's not going to
remove Donald Trump the emoluments
violate it's not going to remove Donald
Trump so the question Landon is asking
is when we all have to contend with
which is are our systems of checks and
balances too much subject to the whims
of the party that is in control of them
I think the answer is yes I don't
believe that the founders ever
considered when they put these in place
that a president would simply ignore
them the checks and balances are only as
good as their enforcement and our
ability to have them enforced and the
ability is basically zero zilch right
now so while I don't like to accept that
this is the reality
Landon's right that the one way the one
opportunity to give Trump a consequence
like a parent would tell their kid if
you do this you're going to have a
consequence the only opportunity is
voting Trump out in November of 2020 if
he's re-elected there will be no other
consequences during his second term and
he will serve that second term and then
leave he's not going to be indicted
after he leaves the White House forget
that if people are holding out hope for
that there's one opportunity and it's
simply saying at the ballot box we
reject you we reject you by such
overwhelming numbers that even foreign
interference and voting machine nonsense
and all of the stuff and vote purging
voter rolls we reject you by such
overwhelming numbers that even those
things can't keep you in the Oval Office
it's one opportunity
Landon's right it's a sad reality but
that's the reality we're dealing with we
are going to talk on the bonus show
today about the black Texas teen who is
told to cut his hair his dreadlocks in
order to walk at graduation what is all
that about many people outraged we will
also talk about new research where it
appears as though we figured out why
stress turns people's hair gray okay we
will discuss that and in addition to
that New Jersey is mandating severance
pay for workers facing mass layoffs and
that in and of itself is triggering a
lot of people who I guess don't think
that the workers deserve severance pay
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show become a member at join
pakman.com to get instant access the
impeachment coupon code is impeached 50
we are at 103 new members we're using
the impeach 50 coupon code help us make
it a hundred and four we will also be
continuing our mmm endless marathon
streams of the impeachment trial of
donald trump if you're listening to this
we are probably streaming right now come
find us on YouTube and twitch we will
otherwise talk to you on the bonus show
or on tomorrow's program
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]